ce qui suit on reconnaît audio tout
ce
vingt piges dans la même pièce [ __ ]
moi j'aurais pété un câble pourquoi
pourquoi quelqu'un a pu faire ça qu'est
ce que toi tu as bien pu faire tiens j'y
crois que ce sera pas de trop non sans
mal café et alors tu comptes faire quoi
allô bonjour je sers c'était comment
cette première journée de liberté
vous êtes qui je pense que nous sommes
seuls responsables de nos choix et que
nous devons accepter les conséquences de
chacun de nos actes de nos maux et de
nos pensées tout au long de notre vie
ce sont des paroles d'elisabeth kugler
rousseff est aujourd'hui je veux que
vous vous songiez à chaque mot est
pensée qui ont jalonné
à temps
misérable existence
il y aura déçu
une proposition formelle qui en cas de
réussite
je sers vous aidera je vends à doëlan
est même je pensais trouver le bonheur
peut être aux côtés de notre adorable
fille mia mia n'a rien à voir avec ça